I think the word marriage was probably
said way too many times in this video I
[Music]
asked her one morning like what are you
doing today she said a lot I said you
want to go to Texas and she met my
family a month and a half and I'd say I
know my family and I know that there are
handful they make me nervous
they bring a nice boy home I am nervous
to dive into these questions because I
have no idea what is gonna be asked
today what was your first impression of
my family I really liked them they're
all super smart her mom's like the
friendliest person ever what about my
dad I don't know does my family make you
nervous
hmm would your parents say is my best
quality they're obsessed with the fact
that you're a teacher in Indian culture
teachers are considered gurus and the
fact that you're a math teacher which is
how many kids do your parents want us to
have I've never had that discussion with
them before I never talked about
grandkids what mom do you don't talk
about grandkids stories I'm 20 floors
the expectation really is there what do
you mean like no pressure right what do
you think is my family's weirdest family
tradition so in the Hindu or is it
Indian tradition where you go and touch
the elder touching oh yeah that's what I
thought you were gonna say you touch
their feet and then they killed you and
sometimes they give you money am i your
parents favorite girlfriend or boyfriend
yes you're their favorite they really
like you a little annoying how much they
like you actually makes me happy what is
one thing that my family does that
annoys you you tell your family
everything I just had a cold and
everyone knew maybe that's your father
what is one thing your mom doesn't like
about me and I know you're talking yeah
yeah I feel bad they don't like that you
don't visit enough
that's so not it she lied she's lied I'd
rather hear that then the truth does
your family thing I'm the one they know
you're the ones
I'm just really glad that my parents
won't be able to understand this because
they don't speak English
[Music]